[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Cassie's
in Denver hi Cassie how are you doing
well how are you better than I deserve
what's
up um so my husband and I are on baby
step two um in the process of paying off
our debts and um we discovered before we
got married that um my husband had about
$177,000 in student debt um to kind of
explain the situation his parents agreed
in when they got divorced to pay for
their kids college tuition um so at the
start of each semester my husband's mom
would send him cash and his dad would
ask that he take out a loan in my
husband's name that his dad um verbally
agreed to pay back at the end of um
College basically so um my husband also
worked full-time 40 hours he ended up
getting all of his tuition
reimbursed that at the end of each
semester he would send his mom the cash
back and his dad the other half and he
thought he was paying those loans off
but come to find out he spent that money
instead and now my husband still has
$177,000 in student loans in his name
with his dad's verbal agreement to pay
it back well I think we see why they got
a
divorce yes one of the many reasons um
that he's poor with money but we are not
that he borrows money that he steals
money from his kids I mean what kind of
guy is
this yeah and it's kind of to the point
where we really we're in the we have a
four-month-old we want to purchase a
house soon um the question is you know
is that debt fall on us or it's in your
husband's name yeah exact and so do we
delay buying the house to pay that off
yes okay I'm
sorry I'm guess I'm guessing your
father-in-law I mean this guy sounds
like a real upstanding twerp um I'm
guessing he doesn't have $177,000 to
honor his word and pay this off right uh
he lives pay check to paycheck and
probably will for the rest of his life
yeah and for some reason we just trusted
that he was going to go through with
this whole deal but your husband did all
this when he was a kid he gave your dad
I mean he's a he's a college kid right
yeah mean you're 17 18 your parents
finances are your finances yeah he well
he so he sent him the he sent him the
money back then he has sent him money
since you all been
married correct he sent him the money at
the end of each
semester being paid off yeah yeah so
what's your household
income uh about 116 how much money do
you
have um right now we have you mean like
in savings mhm um so we have our
thousand emergency fund and then we're
just paying off our other debts
including oh so you have you're working
a debt
snowball yes I'm sorry Cassie how much
other debt have you guys
got um so I have about 12,000 students
and then I have 23,000 on a car I'm
actively trying to sell it and get a
lesser car and he has about10 th000 on
his truck that we've been snowballing so
okay well I'm guessing
that this
pattern of lack of integrity and
irresponsibility has already put a
strain on your husband's relationship
with his dad not counting not counting
this here if you just took this out it
was already a
strain no they haven't my husband was
pretty clueless until I got in the
picture he didn't you know he he's he's
of the mindset it's his dad's
responsibility it was written no no no
no no you misunderstand me your your
your husband's dad is a
twerp okay the student loan not the
first time he was a twerp correct yes so
I'm guessing that his dad your dad your
husband is already strained just because
his dad doesn't do the stuff he says
he's going to do in general correct yes
he's and you're right he has done this
before he off he says going to be there
for Christmas he doesn't come or he says
he's going to be there at 6:00 he comes
at 10:00 cuz he just doesn't the world
revolves around him it doesn't occur to
him that he's supposed to keep his word
on
anything Y and that's why they're not
married anymore I mean that's you know
so what what I'm pointing out is is the
student loan is just a one more Brick in
the Wall o of this guy's life it's
because it's very seldom that you'd have
this as a standalone issue in his life
in in the father-in-law's life so my
point is yeah put it in you you you owe
it legally you're going to have to pay
it it's not going to go away until y'all
pay it so put it in your debt snowball
I'm so sorry you're having to do that
but then what youall need to do is step
back and if I'm in your shoes this
pisses me off a
lot because it delays when you get your
house a
little and I
would require that um if I'm you I don't
require is not the right word I
would want uh my spouse to say out loud
how bad this is and not just act like
this is okay if your husband act like
this is okay it's going to make you
really angry this is not okay this is
not okay does he still trust that his
dad's gonna pay this I don't understand
yes yes he does and he did it for his
sister as well and she he's actually
miss payments on her plan so her credit
got really messed up from it there's
nothing in the entire story that
indicates he's ever going to pay this
yeah and so your husband owning that is
going to help
you relationally with your husband and
help you emotionally if I'm in your
shoes this is me anyway it's going to
help me if my wife if this is my wife
and she came in she goes look this is
awful I'm so sorry we got to pay this
and it's wrong and he's not going to do
it I wish he would do it I just He's
Just Not That guy he's the guy that
doesn't do what he says he's going to do
he's that guy and so
it it that's for you and your husband
cuz there's nothing either one of y'all
are going is going to change the twerp
the twerp's just a
twerp he just is I mean he's just over
there and you're not going to change him
and no amount of angry is going to make
there's no justice in this
story Justice will not be done in this
story this side of heaven right because
Justice would be the old man paid the
bill right but that's nobody in this
within the earshot of our microphones
right now 30 million people listening to
this call none of them think he's going
to pay the bill your husband's the only
one so he needs to own that for the sake
of your all's relationships you what I'm
saying does that make sense to you yes
it does in know I'm not asking him to
disown his father or never speak to him
again I'm not suggesting that there's
not molestation or something that's
occurred here there's nothing like that
this is just the old man didn't keep his
word
well yeah that happens a lot I'm I'm
afraid the old lady didn't keep her word
that happens a lot I'm afraid so but you
can love him where you know he's just
that guy over there and it's just I just
love him in his but I'm certainly not
going to do any business with this guy
ever again right not going to trust him
with any money not going to send any
money to him you know you're $117,000 in
the hole to me let's just start the
conversation there yeah so the reality
is you guys earn 62,000 of debt your
debt you make 116 and is a solvable
problem it's but it's going to delay
your home purchase by a few years well
not even but maybe 18 months is what
it's going to take to get rid of all
this debt unless you sell the car it
will happen even sooner so yeah yeah
it's um you're going to get there you're
going to get there it's just but it's
like you got scammed is what it feels
like scammed I'm out the money and I
still I just get scammed I got scammed
by my dad yeah oh my God the person who
supposed to love me that's supposed to
not it's like these parents that steal
their kidss identity it's a certain
level of scum it's a whole another level
of scum when you steal your own kid's
identity and you go open accounts in
your kid's name oh my God that's just
this guy didn't do that but he he's just
he's in the same bucket you know and
it's just awful oh I'm so sorry but the
the the problem is when we get into
these things you get right down to the
facts the facts are Cassie that your
husband has a student loan in his
name and no one's going to pay it if
y'all don't so you're in debt so you got
to clean it up that's the facts but the
emotion around the facts is just nasty
well the whole situation from the
beginning just sounded complicated and
sketchy they was like well you take the
down your name and I'll I'll get you you
make the yeah once you say that right
there you you can see what's coming if
Dad's not willing to take out the loan
for himself he wasn't willing to take on
the risk and he was not willing to pay
well yeah he didn't have the money and
he doesn't now he blew it somehow and
Mom's over here handing cash and he's
handing her cash back oh my gosh and
yeah you could tell what happened tell
what happened to that marriage that's
just a
yeah yeah Integrity shows up in
everything and it shows up it always
shows up as a pattern not a singular
event and that's what you're looking for
that's why I was saying that about it
wasn't the first time and it won't be
the last no no it's not going to be the
last time he doesn't keep his word on
something create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life